[Music]
anything you want to tell us about your
girlfriend he's talking about Edith look
I know I made a mistake and I'm sorry
but he is not who you think he is Beck
is a liar Mysterio the Elementals is all
fake he has some sort of Illusion Tech
and that's how he tricked you guys and
he tricked me into giving him Edith
pulled it off the fire monster in Prague
so all that death and destruction we
witnessed was created by this no not
just this I think he's using drones
this is true then Beck's very dangerous
and we need to be smart who else did you
tell about this
Parker
Parker what's wrong it's back he's here
what
no
[Music]
no
hurry
wow Peter wow
I thought we were close
Fury always had to die but not you
I'm hiding back
I tried to help you walk away now you're
making me do this
told me you were just a kid
you told me you wanted to run after that
girl
Peter what's going on I know this isn't
real do you though
okay
[Applause]
you know what's real Peter here
[Music]
I mean look at yourself
[Music]
you are just a scared little kid in a in
a sweatsuit
I created Mysterio to give the world
someone to believe in
I control the truth Mysterio is the
truth
foreign
[Music]
if you were good enough
maybe Tony would still be alive
oh
dad you know I'm right
you made your choice
and all you had to do was step aside
and now you
Fury
[Music]
the next people are trying to find
everyone who could expose him
who'd you tell
um I know you told someone so just tell
me okay who did you tell
who else did you tell I just met an MJ
for my classes maybe net told his
girlfriend Betty but that's it
what You Are So Gone
what I mean as smart as the whip just a
sucker
now all your friends have to die
it's easy to fool people when they're
already fooling themselves
[Music]
it's worth Peter
[Music]
I really am sorry
all right
[Music]